voilà c'est à dire c'est le mois d'août
la france est championne du monde la
france à chaud par contre 1 la france a
soif
la france rêve de quoi la france rêve de
grillades à la fraîche et ben ça tombe
bien parce qu'aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
mon jour spécial grillades 1 c'est
bonjour barbecue le désert
[Musique]
dgo
et
[Musique]
vous demandez si mauroy par message
thomas d'anesthésiant tant qu'il y aura
mis finalement maintenant donc j'attends
une bonne heure et ensuite on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est fini bon alors là je repasse
chez moi faire ma valise parce que je
pars en week-end à la mer je vous
raconte ça dès que je suis posée voilà
c'est fini j'ai fait une petite heure de
train je passe quelques jours à lille
avant de partir en week end à la mer et
du coup bah j'en profite pour vous vous
débriefer la séance avant de commencer
voilà à quoi ressemble le tatouage juste
avant la séance c'est à dire un mois
après la dernière
bon alors moi de mon point de vue les
traits sont peut-être un peu plus pâle
surtout j'ai l'impression que les
contours sont je sais pas comment dire
plus floue le je trouve que le trait est
moins nette
donc il me semble qui se passe quelque
chose on n'est pas on n'est pas rendu un
clairement d'ailleurs j'en ai discuté
avec le médecin qui m'a dit
qu'effectivement il était un petit peu
étonnés parce qu'ils pensaient qu'après
cette séance avec l'ancien laser ça
irait quand même plus vite avec le pico
sûr d'autant plus que à priori c'est une
technique lui l'emploi assez souvent
il commence avec un laser traditionnel
qui est moins cher du coup voilà c'est
mieux pour le client et puis ensuite une
fois que le terme a bien été préparé
avec le laser tradi il balance le pico
sur pour bien finir le boulot
bon là ça va moins vite que ce qu'ils
pensaient au départ
mais on a parlé du nombre de séances
initialement non qui on a elle parlé de
quatre là il m'a dit qu'il attendait de
voir le résultat
après la prochaine séance pour me dire
si si combien on continue parce que je
pense qu'il y aura plus que quatre
sachant qu'aujourd'hui c'était la
troisième donc quand même dixième séance
de laser et j'ai toujours cet énergumène
sur le sur le fessier alors la séance
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
c'était une séance avec la puissance
maximale du laser pico sûr qu'ils ont
utilisés dans ce centre c'est à dire que
l'on peut pas faire plus fort le médecin
qui est extrêmement sympa et très
pédagogue m'a expliqué qu'avec ce type
de laser là
la puissance est liée aux à la taille du
spot c'est à dire la taille du faisceau
laser qu'on envoie pour fragmenter les
pigments c'est à dire que plus est
puissant plus le faisceau est petit donc
là on est plus petit faisceau plus petit
diamètre de spots puissance maximum la
conséquence du fait que le spot soit
très petit c'est que bon il est très
précis et donc très puissant mais aussi
il est peu profond pour aller
profondément il faut élargir un peu le
spot met du coup on perd un petit peu en
puissance donc là pour l'instant ils
tabassent bien en surface avec le plus
le plus puissant possible et
potentiellement là les prochaines
séances il élargira un petit peu le spot
voilà ça c'est pour les petits trucs
techniques et donc les hématomes puisque
j'en ai eu la dernière fois je vous en
avais parlé je poserai la question comme
vous pouvez le voir sur cette photo
j'en ai encore là c'est la photo juste
après la séance d'hier après le train
j'ai retiré le pansement
donc voilà j'ai encore manifestement des
hématomes autour du autour du tracé pour
le médecin c'est normal et pas
inquiétant
lui ça ni potez c'est que le laser
fragmente le pigment l'anc
donc il ya plein de petites particules
qui partent un peu dans tous les sens
sous la peau etc au passage c'est
possible qu elle l abîme des petits
vaisseaux on a plein de petits vaisseaux
partout notamment au niveau de la peau
donc ça saigne hot un petit peu ça fait
comme des bleus mais rien de rien de
méchant
il a utilisé le l'image d'une grenade à
fragmentation
voilà qu'on a de la fragmentation au
niveau de la fesse
concernant la séance mais vous avez vu
sur sur mon visage c'était vraiment en
termes de douleur c'étaient ses
semblables à d'habitude alors fun fact
génotype pas très fun fact dit comme ça
mais bon j'ai eu nautique à cause de la
piscine pendant les vacances et donc je
suis sous antibiotiques et les
antibiotiques ça perturbe un peu mon
transit intestinal donc aux séances un
peu moins sereine que d'habitude parce
que avoir le visage d'une personne sympa
mais qu'on ne connaît pas très bien
finalement aussi proche d'une zone de
guerre terrain potentiellement un peu
miné c'est bon c'est assez peu
rassérénant 1
heureusement que la avec la pommade à st
danger moins mal que les autres fois
parce que sinon à chaque sursaut ça
aurait pu être le drame
tout s'est bien passé
pas d'inquiétude autres fun fact la
personne juste avant moi c'était une
abonnée qui est venu au centre se faire
détatouer après avoir vu une vidéo
alors on a discuté j'en profite pour lui
faire un petit coucou c'était très sympa
mais en plus d'être sympa c'était assez
intéressant parce que elle m'a dit que l
c'était sa deuxième séance donc avec le
pico sur un pareil le même que moi
ll a déjà assez clairement des effets
visibles sur son tatouage
donc voilà c'est quand même plutôt
rassurant sur le lait l'efficacité du
matériel alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que bon elle manifestement c'est
un tatouage autre est beaucoup plus fin
que les miens donc potentiellement rend
moins d'encre une encre moins profondes
mais c'était quand même un tatouage pro1
donc donc avec un truc un truc un peu
costaud et dans tout ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'était un
tatouage encore plus frais que le mien
puisqu'elle l'a fait en février de cette
année donc ça fait quelques quelques
mois et donc ça marche quand même sur
les sur les tatouages raison je dis ça
pour tous les gens qui m'envoient des
commentaires en me disant oui mais tu as
commencé son tatouage était trop frais
c'est pour ça que ça marche pas en
tatouage il a maintenant un an et demi
donc il est plus ils feraient que ça et
preuve c'est que ça marche sur l'état
fois jeux récents voilà donc c'était
intéressant
il ya un autre truc dont je me suis
rendu compte en discutant avec cette
sympathique jeune fille c'est que moi je
vous dis que ça ne fait pas mal du tout
mais c'est parce que je compare avec les
séances que j'ai eus sans aucune pommade
anesthésiante mais on verrait ça chauffe
un petit peu un alors pendant
un peu mais vraiment c'est très peu
douloureux par contre après bah ça se
réveille et ça fait ça fait quand même
un petit peu mal alors pour moi vraiment
encore une fois c'est maintenant ces
crèmes mais pour les gens qui n'ont pas
connu ça avant quand c'est leur première
séance
vous prévoyez de faire du laser sachez
que ça va quand même puis côté un petit
peu pendant un petit peu et que ça va
chauffer un peu après voilà je préfère
jeune je ne veux pas vous mentir préfère
être honnête vous irez les choses
franchement ça m'a piqué 1 donc bon bah
on va faire la petite on va faire le
petit comparatif habituel donc ça je
vous ai déjà montré mais je vous leur
monde ça c'est la faute au juste avant
la séance
ça vous l'avez vu aussi c'est la photo
juste après la séance quelques quelques
de trois heures après la séance disons
ça c'est la faute aux le lendemain là
c'est deux jours plus tard et là c'est
au bout de quatre jours donc vous voyez
si on joue un petit peu sur les sur les
traits voilà il ya des endroits où ça
disparaître un petit peu il ya des
endroits où ça disparaît complètement là
dans l'oreille on a déjà parlé mais
vraiment c'est parti complètement
et puis il ya les yeux quand même
à noter que cette fois il n'a pas passé
le laser sur les yeux parce que je lui
ai dit que j'avais vraiment eu des clubs
vénère la dernière fois il a vu que
effectivement la peau été bien abîmées
des séances précédentes
donc il y avait un petit peu mollo mais
tout ce qu'il y avait à l'intérieur des
yeux je vous remets les yeux au tout
début et ça c'est les yeux maintenant
donc on passe des trucs ça va doucement
mais on a deux on a de l'espoir quand
même pour la suite de mes vacances et
ben la vôtre si vous vous faites retirer
un tatouage au laser ne pas exposer la
zone euro soleil dans mon cas c'était
assez peu prévu un de d'exposer sa au
soleil il pas ou alors vraiment de façon
un peu espiègle mais ça l'a très vite et
peuvent pas bon ça a pas de souci alors
petit problème
en revanche concernant la baignade en
mer je vous ai dit je vais passer
quelques jours quelques jours à la mer
le médecin m'a dit que c'était quand
même mieux d'attendre quelques jours il
m'a dit une semaine parce que sinon ça
pique
là on va pas y être complètement à la
semaine
mais moi ce fan quand je vois la mer moi
je sens que je plonge dedans directement
je suis un dauphin donc je suis pas sûr
de tenir sur la plage à regarder les
autres se baigner je pense que je vais
aller me baigner voilà c'est pas
dangereux
c'est juste que c'est comme la la peau
est un peu un petit peu à braser disons
ça risque de piquer un petit peu donc je
vous raconterai ça je retourne à ma
prochaine séance en septembre pour ma
petite rentrée des fesses et puis voilà
bah d'ici là bas qu'est ce qui se passe
pour ceux qui ont des vacances la bonne
vacances pour ceux qui n'ont pas bon
courage on se retrouve à la rentrée
voilà je vous le dis comme je le pense
et puis d'ici là évidemment prenez soin
de vous prenez soin des autres mettez
vous bien et portez vous bien
[Musique]